first up our story is we're gonna talk
dating etiquette for the modern dater
here's a question
i like this one i really love this story
when can you ask the person you're
seeing
to delete their dating app i mean how
juicy
is this this is literally modern romance
absolutely and you know what it's it's
like a conversation you have
to have i had a friend true story she
was dating somebody on one of the dating
apps and then
she it was like kind of getting serious
so she was like i'm gonna go on the
dating app and get off now
and when she logged in she saw that he
was still on and had just
updated all of his pictures with
pictures that she had taken
of him oh my god and i was like she was
just
mortified i'm like well didn't you have
a conversation with him about
are we doing this now and the answer was
no
she didn't so this just comes down to
communication
a lot of layers well vice actually uh
said when can i ask the person i'm
dating to delete tinder or
you know any dating app and they say
when this question pops up in your head
maybe it's time to have that larger
conversation about defining the
relationship and it's not about
just saying no to other people but yes
to the one
that you're with you know i like your
perspective because i don't think
there's a right
or a wrong you're saying communication
is best and i don't think a
relationship's going to survive without
it period at the beginning middle or end
yeah and if you can't have that
conversation of like are we off the
dating apps
then you shouldn't be in this
relationship right that's like the
starter conversation
your friend's example is a non-starter
for me
all right next drew okay we're getting
into the charlie's angel spirit
with sierra who i love hello giggles
reports that she just posted posted her
latest look
and take a look at this it is full-on
farrah fawcett
yeah the pharah flip is showing up she
looks amazing she does
and it's a huge trend it's now on tick
tock okay oh my god does that remind me
of childhood
right look there's brie larson would you
ever do that
that's a farah faucet i did it in
charlie's angels
there you are there you go that was the
best wig
ever by the way i still have it you do
where where
i cut it i like those wigs are so
expensive i'm not kidding they're made
by
master artists you know from all over
the world these wigs cost
so much money so i keep them and then i
if you're working on a
different film with a different budget
you're like don't worry i got a wig in
my bag
i work on rupaul's drag race i know
about wigs in the bag
exactly you never throw away a wig not a
good one
always reintroduce it well hairstyles
always come back around and so do names
apparently because
fatherly reports a new study of parents
are reaching back to the 1800s to name
their babies
researchers at the family history site
my heritage
crunched census data to find that
ada nora theodore
eliza ella and walter are all making a
comeback
it's about time walter made a comeback i
always think of uh
sleepless in seattle when i hear walter
um while the names of the 1980s and
1990s like
jessica jennifer and amanda have
actually decreased
and have you met a lot of rossi ross's
lately no
i i haven't i i'm glad i don't know
where ross came from i asked my mom when
she goes i just liked it
i just thought she was like a fan of raw
stress for less
and then i asked my dad you know did you
always want to name me ross and do you
know what he wanted to name me
what captain and i'm furious my name is
not captain wouldn't i make a great
captain
it's never too late thank you
i cannot even imagine you as
any other name well i love a
one-syllable name because i'm a busy guy
i got things to do
you know what i mean drew i do ross and
finally
it's time for a brand new segment we're
putting on our drew's new
spin on the traditional advice column in
ask a desk spurt
do it ask a desk that just rolls off the
tongue
[Laughter]
all right now ross and i make no claims
to know any better than anyone
else but listen if you have a conundrum
we
want to help oh we want to help real bad
i know why do i love giving advice
it's like my number one thing to do it's
my favorite thing ever and i'm not
qualified at all
well i will say i have ascertained
extraordinary
advice from great minds throughout my
whole life so
if i can be a funnel of that wisdom you
know what
let me be that and we asked you to
submit your questions about life love
and relationships
and rossi and i will use our combined
years of experience on this earth
to give our best ideas and advice for
you to take or disregard completely
rossi who's our first letter all right i
love this we're just helping our friends
out
this is we hope this letter says
dexperts
i've been with my partner for seven
years sometimes i i lie just a little to
keep the peace
for example they write i watch full
seasons of shows and i don't tell them
when i rewatch them with him as if it's
just the first time
but that is awful but recently his phone
lit up and i read
three of his texts maybe not so bad but
then i also flipped through his notebook
on his desk
i feel terrible do i tell him so i
come clean and have a clean slate or do
i just keep it to myself how do i stop
myself from going down this rabbit hole
of a
slippery movie thriller sign desperately
snooping in chicago
for starters if you have to snoop
something's going on
probably within you agreed agreed i
think it has i think this is all about
this person not so much about the other
person yes
and i will also say the part that i have
a real problem with
is you watching a full season of a show
if my wellington
what if he watched 90 day fiance without
me the wedding is off you understand me
i i that one really gets me going i will
say
that i think it is best to
not snoop i think it it's a slippery
slope
and i think you can get addicted to it
and you can start conjuring up things
that you don't know
you gotta trust you gotta respect
yourself and that other person
so there's two different things at play
here maybe the watching the shows is
kind of cute and innocent
doesn't bother me but the snooping i'd
say cut it off
and just get confident because the
person that you need to work on is you
not them you cannot control what other
people do you can only
control yourself and you want to be the
example of how people should behave
not sitting there like you know hating
yourself the whole time so move on
just move along and be respectful and
let it go
and if there's something burning and
you're really like suspicious of
something
you can also listen to your inner gut on
that yeah if there's something burning
there's probably a cream for that
i hope we get more questions for our
advice column